what up reject nation it's your girl
sally aka sally lamonico aka salamander
but you can only call me salamander if
you subscribe to this channel so hit
that red subscribe button or else we are
not on a nickname basis you need to earn
it
and my love and affection if this is
your first video on this channel that
you are watching hi this video is part
of a series where i am going to be
watching all of the marvel movies in
order from phases one through four
because i have not seen most of the
newer ones i'm a nerd when it comes to
this stuff
i feel stupid
so
this week we are watching captain
america the first avenger i don't really
know why this isn't the first one to be
quite honest maybe just didn't fit well
like maybe they try to do ironman first
i don't know this to me should have been
the first one i'm confusion i'm
confusion and it obviously takes place
during
world war one or two or it's
i'm sorry i'm i swear i'm not stupid
i'm horrible with dates honestly
speaking of dates if you want to watch
my full reaction of this movie please go
to patreon.com the real rejects it would
be a date because we're technically
sitting down watching a full movie
together and you know why wouldn't you
want to go on a date with me so grab
some popcorn if at any point you laughed
during this video or had a similar
reaction or you just enjoyed it and want
to help us out please give a like it
really does help the algorithm it's free
not a lot of things are free in america
apparently also quick shout out to
prepper y'all are the homies for editing
together a super long video for
highlights specifically thank you so
much it's a lot of work and i'm just
watching the movie
ironically it is july 4th weekend and
even though things are not looking great
in america right now i just want to say
happy fourth of july even though this is
coming out probably a month after all
right
america
what is
my god
this one's waited long enough
he didn't even try to move
four guys couldn't open that but he
could
the tesseract was the jewel of odin's
treasure room
[Music]
uh
it's kind of symbolic
it's not for the eyes
of ordinary men
exactly
the order to open fire
fool you cannot control the power you
hold you will burn
okay that's dark disney lord
sorry son look just give me a chance
you'll be ineligible on your asthma
alone
is there anything you can do i'm doing
it
i'm saving your life they should have
made his voice like sound like i hadn't
hit puberty yet because it looks so
weird with him talking that deep and
he's just tiny i don't know i don't know
when to give up do you
hang on this all day
hey
pick on somebody your own size
he kicked his ass like his mama come on
man
well last night
i gotta get you cleaned up why where are
we going
future welcome to the modern marbles
pavilion
and the world know tomorrow
a greater world this reminds me of
tomorrowland at disney
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine being that extra
what if i told you that in just a few
short years
your automobile won't even have to touch
the ground at all with stock rubidic
reversion technology you'll be able to
do just that
we still don't have cars like that
so many important jobs somebody do
collect scrap yes come on there are men
laying down their lives i got no right
to do any less than them that's what you
don't understand don't do anything
stupid until i get back
how can i
taking all the stupid with you oh
represent the strategic scientific
reserve steve rogers do you want to kill
nazis i don't want to kill anyone i
don't like bullies i don't care where
they're from well there are already so
many big men fighting maybe what we need
now it's a little guy that's offensive
gentlemen i'm agent carter i supervise
all operations for this division must be
the accent queen victoria thought i was
signing up for the us arms i got a few
moves i know you'll like
thank god he needed to be punched
[Music]
that flag means we're only at the
halfway point
that's me
nobody's got that flag in 17 years let's
go get back in the formation
rogers i said fall in
[Music]
that's the way to do it
hodge passed every test we gave him he's
big he's fast he obeys orders he's a
soldier he's a bully you win wars
guts
my god
get away
get back
back
is this a test no [ __ ] it's a test
he's still skinny
yeah that's intimidating for sure
somebody get that kitty sandwiched
comfortable
it's a little big his head is so big
two
one
they couldn't have done it slower oh my
lord
oh no
we will proceed
[Music]
that's 10
um
[Music]
oh
my god
it's the stock
and he comes out looking like a snake
[Music]
consent
[Music]
no not german stanley tucci
respect your elders
[Music]
nice
uh
[Music]
no
[Music]
go
[Music]
that kid is a trooper
oh
that's a whole lot of nope from me
who the hell are you the first of many
cut off one hit
hill hydra
okay i did understand that greek
mythology reference
now he's like oh look what i just did
with my new muscles hydra is assembling
an arsenal to destroy my enemies in one
stroke wherever they are regardless of
how many forces they possess quite
simply gentlemen
i have harnessed the power of thoughts
thank you schmidt
berlin is on this map
let's do this
sorry
if you're going at the schmidt i want in
do you want to serve your country on the
most important battlefield of the war
sir
that's all i want you just got promoted
i don't know if i can do this nothing
too sell a few bonds bonds buy bullets
bullets kill nazis bing bang boom
series e defense bonds each one you buy
is a bullet in the barrel of your best
guy's gun
i need to volunteer i already
volunteered how do you think i got here
bring that the girls
hi what are you doing here schmidt sent
out a force to osama 200 men went up
against him in less than 50 returned
your audience contained what was left of
the 107th the 107th oh my god
are you planning a rescue mission yeah
it's called winning the war but if you
know where they are why not at least 30
miles behind the lines
through some of the most heavily
fortified territory in europe we lose
more men and would say but i don't
expect you to understand that because
you're a chorus girl yeah that you made
him that what do you plan to do walk to
austria that's what it takes you heard
the colonel your friend is most likely
dead you don't know that even so he's
devising a strategy if he detects by the
time he's done that it could be too late
hmm tell me you thought i was meant for
more than this
did you mean that
every word you gotta let me go
but i love you
the hydra camp is in crossbow between
these two mountain ranges it's a factory
of some kind agent carter we're not in
too much of a hurry i thought we could
stop off in lucerne for a late night
fondue oh god stark is the best civilian
pilot i've ever seen he's mad enough to
brave this airspace we're lucky to have
him so are you two
do you
fondue
that's like the first time i've seen him
smile the whole movie
[Music]
[Music]
who you supposed to be
um
captain america
[Music]
this is like star wars but on earth
no what are you doing i forces are
outmatched
mighty stop
it's me
steve come on
i thought you were smaller
[Music]
what were they doing dan why was he on a
table like that
what happened to you i joined the army
oh my god
captain america
how exciting
i am a great fan of your films
oh dr askin managed it after all
you got no idea
every day
oh oh my god
no matter what life
told you you say i was his greatest
success
oh
no wonder like he had an awful facelift
job
you don't have one of those do you
you are deluded captain villains never
have noses
it's so gross
he's all right
senator brandt
what
[Music]
yes
i am honored to present this medal for
valor to my personal friend
captain america captain that's your cue
i thought he'd be taller
baltic and the sixth one was
about
here 30 40 miles west of the maginot
line
she is just looking at him like with
those bedroom eyes
[Music]
i want every allied eyeball looking for
that main hydra base i'll need a team
we're already putting together the best
man
with all due respect sir so am i we
barely got out of there alive and you
want us to go back
that's rather
fun actually
i'm in we're in
i'll always fight howard has some
equipment for you to
he's a strong guy but not strong enough
not to look down
you don't like music i do actually
i might even when this is all over go
dancing then what are we waiting for the
right partner
no 800 captain
yes ma'am
he even looked at
captain
i'm looking for mr stark he's in with
colonel phillips of course you're
welcome to wait read about what you did
just doing what needed to be done
sounded like more than that you saved
nearly 400 men
be careful with blondes
you're a hero
well that you know that that depends on
the definition the women of america they
owe you the thanks
[Music]
and uh
seeing as they're not here
no don't ruin it with agent carter you
freaking [ __ ]
captain
we're ready for you if you're not
otherwise occupied
i'm kidding i don't call women [ __ ] i
was just joking right now you are just
like all the rest well what about you
and stark how do i know you two haven't
been
fonduing you still don't know a bloody
thing about women
what about this one no no that's just a
prototype what's it made of vibranium
that's the rarest metal on earth what
you're holding there that's all we've
got i'm sure the captain has some
unfinished business what do you think
yes i think it works
i had some ideas about the youtube i
like her i know she has a show i need to
watch it
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
oh wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
imagine
you are failing
we are close to an offensive that will
shake the planet
i know he's supposed to look scary but
he looks just
funny to me
i had him on the ropes i know he did
watch out
oh don't let go he said hang on why
would you like
[Music]
after all that and saving him
dang he was cute too i'm
but doesn't he come back or something i
feel like i've seen him in something he
better he was too cute to die how much
time we got according to my new best
friend under 24 hours where is he now
hydra's last base is here in the alps
500 feet below the circle
it's not like we can just knock on the
front door that's exactly what we're
gonna do
okay batman
[Applause]
presented my genius and tried to deny me
what was rightfully mine but he gave you
everything what made you so special
nothing
i'm just a kid from brooklyn
why did that piss them all
i can do this all day
oh of course you can of course but
unfortunately i am on a tight schedule
so am i
why did he just run off uh
like you had um
but he just oh it looked like he just
slipped and fell
fire not
[Music]
get
friends
[Music]
that looks like fun
there we go
go get him
he's about to pass
oh
oh my god oh my god
i would ship bricks
if i were either of them
not new york
that's where i live
[Music]
yeah let's hit a bomb
oh my god
disney what the
oh my god
[Music]
that was so dumb why would you do that
couldn't they all get like sucked out of
the
plane if there's a window open
uh again dumb
we
you just have the power of the dog i
have seen the future cats not my future
[Music]
what
i gotta put her in the water
please don't do this we have time we can
work it out
you're gonna need a rain check on that
dance
i was wondering why they didn't dance
all right
a week next saturday at the stalk club
you got it
eight o'clock
don't you
i'll show you how
just be there
we'll have the band play something
i'd hate to slow on you
steve
steven
[Music]
where am i you're in a recovery room in
new york city where am i really i'm
afraid i don't understand the game it's
from may 1941 i know cause i was there
cancer rogers wait
[Music]
hey soldier
you're in the
future you thought it best to break it
to you slowly
break what you've been asleep cap for
almost 70 years you gonna be okay
yeah
yeah i just
i had a date
[Music]
well
that was captain america very very
different i will say i was wondering how
queensid was going to do a war movie and
so
i yeah it's weird like i've never seen
this sort of subject matter in like a pg
or
pg-13-ish rating obviously war movies
are usually extremely violent and so
yeah i was i was just really curious the
whole time watching like how far are
they gonna go with this minus that guy
going through the freaking propellers
could have done without that scene but
honestly it was pretty
enjoyable i just think they could i
honestly feel like they could have been
a little more
more gritty with it it seemed still very
polished and obviously the cgi was
noticeable in this movie a lot uh maybe
because it was a little earlier what i
don't know what year this was i mean
some of the cgi kind of took me out of
it a little bit i'm not gonna lie like i
saw the green screen in her hair and
stuff like that but other than that it
was different
it was different
i thought the ending was really
heartfelt i feel like it didn't linger
long enough for me like as i started to
get teary-eyed it just
jumped into the future i don't know that
could have lingered more for me but i
really liked that whole sequence where
he's about to go under and
he's talking about the date like that
really got me
agent carter i love her i feel like i
can really
i was not in the army though but
i kind of wish there were there had been
a few more moments between captain
america and her that were
good i feel like obviously they had a
lot of attention and stuff and she got
mad at him and that's that was hilarious
to me
um because it just seemed natural but i
i really wish there had been just a
little bit more with them to make the
ending stronger but i was i really felt
i did feel it though i felt that they
never got their dance that's gonna
bother me that's just really gonna
bother me we just i mean the whole time
i'm gonna be watching the avengers i'm
like they don't remember it
and that's so sad and she died thinking
that he was dead
man he's gonna need therapy i honestly
just feel really bad for him like i know
he's gonna be in the avengers i just
feel bad for him like that's a doozy i
can see why maybe he'd be a little
angsty he seemed really serious in this
movie he's a very serious character so i
like when we got a few moments where he
smiled and was happy he went through it
so i'm just curious to see how his
character
develops and how
he handles the modern world because to
be honest
i'd be pretty mad too
the villain
wasn't that scary to me i feel like
again
for a good movie like it's gotta have a
good villain and i feel like obviously i
think they were trying to go with a
whole hitler concept with him where he
just wants to watch the world burn i
guess but i don't know that wasn't super
fleshed out for me his motivation
obviously so then the ending kind of
felt
with the villain at least it kind of
felt a little
abrupt it wasn't like a big payoff for
me he was just like i'm holding it and
then i explode i guess
i don't know this just felt like it was
more about captain america than it was
about a villain so
i feel that there were aspects about
this movie that i did like i don't know
there were a lot of lines in this movie
that i thought were funny and great like
i'm not gonna kiss you that that really
got me i loved that the acting was
really great in this movie i feel like a
lot of war movies focus on the
relationships with the soldiers and the
men
fighting closely with each other i think
a great example of that is the movie
fury i guess i kind of thought that they
were going to focus a lot maybe on the
relationships with the men that
continued to fight with captain america
after he saved their lives and so i i
don't know i guess i just wanted more if
that makes sense like i mean it would
have been really great to explore those
other men and why they continued to
fight with captain america and i know he
lost his best friend i just thought they
were going to do more with the other men
and that that would have been a really
cool story for like a ween's war movie
this was interesting it achieved its
goal of of tackling this very dark
subject of like nazis for example and
making it kid friendly i just yeah i
think they could have gone a little
grittier with it maybe they could have
made it feel a little more like a war
movie but i see why they didn't also
like this also worked i did really love
how it was shot i loved the aesthetic of
it i loved that it was
very
vintage looking and a lot of the colors
were like you know green tan muted the
colors in this movie and the set
decorations and everything
like that it just looked really cool i
also understand now why this wasn't the
first movie i know he's the first
avenger technically but obviously having
known the information that i do now
about iron man and his father i now get
why this movie was a little later
because now you're understanding how uh
tony stark's father kind of fits in with
this whole world and how he did help you
know basically first start the avengers
is really fascinating and he's kind of a
good guy which is nice i'm sure the
tesseract comes back i get why this
movie came a little later and came after
iron man um that was really interesting
this movie had a lot of great lines
cinematography and the fight sequences
were fun i don't remember a lot of the
star wars movies to be honest that'll
probably be another
series but it kind of felt star
wars-esque to me with the pupil you know
the guns that shoot out lasers but it
was interesting seeing like an old
vintage sort of set but with those that
kind of threw me off but i mean it was
also cool it was just a different
atmosphere for sure f4 war movie yeah
overall i'm just really excited to watch
the avengers now i know that everyone
was talking about the winter soldier and
civil war is the civil war the other one
i just heard more about those movies
than i did with this one so i'm excited
this obviously is a huge setup for the
character so i'm excited to see the rest
of those movies and again to see how his
character develops and how he deals with
all of this trauma adapting to
everything it was a fun movie i i
enjoyed all the action even though i
didn't quite understand the science
behind
the lasers and the tesseract and all
that that got a little confusing either
i'm stupid and i couldn't follow i
follow along lager it was just
seemed a little plot holy to me but it
was fun it could have been a much darker
movie so i loved the aesthetic of this
movie it was really it was really
different anyway if you enjoyed this
reaction please give it a like it does
help the algorithm turn on that
notification bell to know when i post
the avengers
video that'll be fun and then we'll be
hopping right into phase two i'm excited
i'm super excited and you should be too
america and i'll see you next week